SS to high heaven I think Taylor Swift
is behind it
all she's be a
distraction yeah she is the whole time
she already is that reminds me of the
Toronto Raptors when they had a super
fan that guy went to every single home
and away game home and away game when
they sucked and they did all of these
things and the guy was a great guy a
positive guy yeah you just loved him
when you saw the interview then all of a
sudden the Raptors get good and Drake
starts coming around you used to call me
on your cell phone you used to you used
to they showed Drake more than they
showed the head coach of their
own goddamn team right that's what
Taylor Swift is gonna do to Patrick
Mahomes wife and she's gonna get upset
she's gonna be like oh p no they're
jumbo TR as much they're already friends
she she's she's already getting her in
so she could be part of it she knows a
women are they always start off as
friends Paul yeah it goes off the rails
the next thing you know you lose a
golfing buddy